well we live it's not on my end
hello alright I'm just for everything to
load on my side and then we'll get
rolling alright right okay I think we
are live welcome to another ask a career
coach my name is Martin McGovern and
today we're going to be chatting about
all your questions but starting with the
topic of elevator pitching a little bit
about me I have a strong background in
marketing and career development so a
lot of what we'll be talking about today
is not only you know the ins and outs of
the job search but also how to use some
marketing tactics to help you get
noticed and stand out among the crowd of
people we're all buying for those
coveted positions out in the workforce
I'm gonna give us just a couple of
minutes to let folks join we have a few
we have about fourteen well 26 miles big
jump we've got 26 people in the call
right now so I'm just gonna give a
couple of minutes for people to join us
and while we're waiting if you have any
questions please put them in the chat
and we'll be collecting all your
questions and trying to get to as many
of them as possible throughout this call
so we'll just take a brief pause and
start adding your questions in
alright let's say we're getting some
shout outs of where people are at in the
world San Jose Schaumburg Illinois
you're right by me I'm in Chicago
another Illinois let's say we have some
familiar faces joining the chat welcome
everybody we got New York we got Germany
we got Chile India Bolivia Batavia
Illinois
I love it we got some great questions
pouring in we've got some good people on
the call thank you all for taking time
out of your day night whatever time it
is in your time zone and joining us for
today's career call all right wait we
got people from all over the place all
right I'm gonna jump into our first
topic and what we're gonna be talking
about initially here today is the
elevator pitch and there's a lot of
different ways to do an elevator pitch
and I'm sure we've all heard a number of
things online read articles been told
different things for different people
but really what you want to do is you
want to figure out what's right for you
and so when you're thinking about the
elevator pitch it tends to be a bit of a
sort of uneasy thing to get into because
a lot of us are introverted and we don't
really like selling ourselves and it
seems like a very marketing selling kind
of thing but there's a few different
things that you can think about when
doing your pitch that'll make it a
little bit more natural a little bit
easier so the first thing you want to
keep in mind is that it's really not
about boasting or telling your whole
life story or anything along those lines
it's about communicating a need that
someone has and then and then explaining
how you're able to help or bring value
to solving that need so an example of
this would be in a breakdown of a 3-part
breakdown of what an elevator pitch
could look like you would open it by
saying do you know how and then you sort
of open up a problem so for me it's do
you know how people tend to be fairly
overwhelmed by the job search and lose
motivation because of the high amounts
of rejection and non-response on the
internet so that's a big opening right
you open with do you know how then you
follow it up by the second piece which
is what I do so what I do is create
webinars career cues to nays and videos
that help people get or and so that's it
just right there
a little baggage I started getting into
the whole thing so what I do is I
create videos around career topics and
then part three that do what for other
people so we want to say what is it the
outcome of what we do so the outcome is
that help motivate and get people
motivate people and get them back to the
job search so they can go find their
dream job so you know how people get
demotivated I create videos that
motivate see how it's a nice arch art
there and then what you can do when you
finish is open the question up back to
them what are the things that you're
working on so now you've got a rapport
going and a bit of a ping-pong back and
forth if any of you like that style you
can go to the videos that we've been
putting up on LinkedIn and YouTube and
take a look at some of the videos I know
some of the folks who are joining us
today have actually recorded their own
versions and posted them up so it's
awesome but you put yours in the
comments there and we'll help you you
know refine them and make them better or
put them in the comments here and we'll
help you refine them together but that's
just kind of the opening here I wanted
to get us talking and thinking about how
to put ourselves out there how to talk
about ourselves and wit that doesn't
feel so weird and how to really engage
people with what we're trying to
communicate alright our next question
comes from Christian oh the question is
should I include non-coding related
roles in my resume that show leadership
now this was actually much more in-depth
question that we received prior to the
call and so I kind of cleaned it up so
that everyone can can listen to it but
one thing specifically about Christian
is that this non coding experience that
he's talking about is that it was
something that he had built something he
had founded and so in a case like this
where you are working on something that
is really interesting or that you're
passionate about and that you maybe
built it is extremely important to
include that in your resume when you're
thinking about your resume really you
really want it to be the highlight reel
of the things that you hope to talk
about in the interview so a funny thing
about it is that we tend to think oh I
should only ever talk about
things that are exactly related to this
role but what ends up happening is that
we leave off a lot of stuff that people
want to hear about and people want to
talk about I'll give an example from an
early resume that I put together in one
of my first jobs at the very very bottom
just the last line I wrote also the lead
singer of a ska band called the you know
but others can name was back then and
that was one of those fun things that I
I put in there just one quick line and
it came up in every interview and became
this really interesting talking point
because if number one showed my skill as
a public speaker because I was able to
get up on stage and butylene singer of a
band but it was also just a weird thing
that people didn't put on the resume so
that's a bit out there but I would say
that if you've built an organization of
your own even if you're not coding as
the skill in there and that's the job
you're trying to go after it does show
your leadership skills it shows your
soft skills which was your organization
skills it shows your people skills all
that good stuff and then use you know
cement your you're like I should get
this job mindset by backing it up with
the actual technical skills you have and
in other examples so I highly recommend
you include that all right our next
question here
all right now I'm terrible at names so I
very much apologize if I butcher
people's names from around the world I'm
a Midwest guy and it's just not not my
forte but we have a so he'll your
question was how should I improve upon
my skill sets when my current job is not
allowing me to do so this is a big
question and it's actually one where
it's this whole mindset of asking for
forgiveness or asking for permission and
one of the things that's really
interesting is there's a lot of
different ways to build your skill set
so if you're waiting around for someone
else to tell you to do something you'll
never end up doing it people just have a
million other things going on and we
really can't wait if we're interested in
something so for instance the reason I'm
even talking to any of you today is
because early on someone had come to me
and said hey I need help with my
personal brand and I just said all right
let's do it
I was working in advertising at the time
I had a full time job and on the
weekends I started helping people with
personal brands and so if you have time
in your schedule outside of work to
start developing a new skill maybe
building a small side project side
hustle
even if it's just something very very
small like your own website or something
like that you know these are the only
way that you're going to be able to
build a skill set that you want in the
future if it's not in your current job
right now so I highly recommend finding
depending on your situation finding how
much time you have and and and how much
it conflicts with your actual jobs you
don't indicate neglect that but if you
have a little passion project or a
little a skill set that you want to
learn definitely go after it
and interestingly enough if you do that
and it is somewhat related to your job
it could actually you know show that you
are someone who's a go-getter someone
who takes it upon themselves to learn on
top of their regular job so again that
same example when I was working in
advertising assertive podcast on
and you know there was no there was
never going to be a time in my job at
that time where they would give me a
podcast to run but because I was doing
it on the side they saw that oh this is
someone who is really interested in new
media and all these different things and
I started being pulled into
conversations at work because they knew
I was doing these things outside of work
so it can actually really help you to
work on these side projects and if they
you know go really well you know then
you share them with other people and
maybe get a little bit more clout inside
your company
all right Raul and ask the question can
you talk about case study questions and
how to handle them
sometimes I feel I make too many
assumptions and talk quick unsure of
your take on that when it comes to case
study questions well I mean listen let's
take a more general part of your
question here I feel like I make a lot
of assumptions and talk too quick this
is a basically at the end of the day the
best way that you can start dealing with
this side of the coin is to start
thinking about how can I practice
speaking and how can I hear myself talk
through these things out loud so you
know how do you do a case study question
there's a million resources online go to
the Meuse comm go to any of these
websites that have case studies pull
down your favorite case study questions
and then don't prep but don't do
anything just look at the first one and
try and answer it as succinctly as you
possibly can while recording yourself
and then what you'll get to do is you'll
finish you know rambling your answer and
then you get to go back and listen to
your response and there is something
about hearing yourself out loud that
really helps your brain slow down and
process how it is that you speak so the
next time you talk you are are you know
way more prepared because you kind of
realize oh I say um too much or I pause
too much or I ramble too much and you
can kind of go back and do that a
handful of times until you get
comfortable talking and hearing yourself
and talking and hearing yourself and you
just your brain will naturally start
self-correcting once it can hear itself
because the thing is when we're just
talking out loud to other people the
words are just flying they're never
coming back to us and so take a second
in order to practice this download a
bunch of case study questions and just
give your answers while recording
yourself listen to a back a handful of
times and keep on improving it'll really
really help you
slow down and maybe make fewer
assumptions and do better in those
interviews I hope that answered your
question
Peggy thank you for joining us again
and congrats on sharing your your
elevator pitch video with the community
I thought that was awesome so welcome
back you asked question if we can share
some good LinkedIn profiles to follow
it's not something new right this second
on this call because I'd have to go
research but I will take that into
account and go try and find some great
profiles to share with you all maybe I
can make that into a career tips video
down the road Alicia how can I tell
stories from the projects I created in
my business analytics nanodegree mmm
storytelling storytelling is one of
those skill sets that is very very
difficult it's one of those things that
you've got to really think about and
learn over time and this goes back to
our opening of the elevator pitch the
reason you break it into those three
pieces of here's the problem here's how
I solve it and here is the result of my
work is because it gives you a nice
story arc the same thing goes for any of
the things that you're working on here
what you want to do is take a step back
from the project that you created and
instead of just doing the linear walk
through of I did this I did this I did
this I did this I did this boom a linear
story is usually the least compelling
story what we want to do is we want to
get the linear story down on paper or
into an audio format or something that
we can hear and then we want to take a
step higher in the storytelling chain of
how to how to tell this story so the
first thing is to identify the problem
that was solved in your project and then
open up your story with that problem so
let's go back to the elevator pitch you
know how this problem exists in the
world
so we worked on a project that
identified this big problem that we saw
that existed within companies or
whatever the project is that you're
working on my job was to build a project
that would address these issues using
certain types of code or certain types
of organization whatever the thing might
be and because we were able to identify
this problem and implement this solution
we got XYZ results and so that's how you
can start telling the story about these
projects that you've been working on
because every single thing that you've
worked on is trying to solve something
even if it's just you know better UI or
sorting something better or pulling an
API whatever the thing might be so I
hope that addresses your question but if
you have more de to ask on that please
put it in the chat
all right um salim asks when should I
start working on my LinkedIn profile
that's a great question
and very kind of open-ended the answer
is now and always and what I mean by
that is if you do not have a LinkedIn
profile the number one thing you have to
do is just get a LinkedIn profile
because people are going to search you
and then you need to make it as you know
get the basics up there a profile
picture your work experience all the
titles and everything and just get the
basics if you get the basics you're
already like leagues ahead of anyone who
doesn't even have the profile all right
so once you get the basics down and it
seems like you're talking about updating
it
well you said working so I'm not sure if
you have one or don't have one but as
soon as you get it up then the question
becomes how much effort do I want to put
into my LinkedIn profile um we see that
there is a diminishing return the more
information that you put into it but
then it kind of flips if you are
creating on LinkedIn so if you have a
basic profile that has all your jobs
listed and a profile picture and a small
description you're usually pretty good
to start you know to say alright I'm in
a good spot let's go start applying to
jobs let's go start networking let's
move on to the other pieces of the job
search because what we don't want you to
do is get into a sort of productive
procrastination loop where you spend the
next four months creating your LinkedIn
and never get to the actual job search
if you'd like to you know fill it out
more and put in good descriptions and
things like that I think that's
something you can just sort of do in
increments over time while you're also
networking and interviewing and sending
out applications you don't want to wait
too long to start your actual search
which is getting out in meeting people
then you know if you've got a pretty
robustly filled out you've got
descriptions for everything
all the sections are filled out it's
well organized and it feels pretty solid
you can really kind of lower your I need
to update all these things on a regular
basis mindset and you can switch into I
want to create content on this platform
or maybe not create content but at least
engage in this platform so that's where
you start putting social posts up it is
a social platform at the end of the day
so what you want to do is you want to be
liking people's comments for liking
people's posts commenting on people's
posts sharing articles and fun things
that you've come across and if you
really want to take it to the next level
posting your own articles because they
have a publisher on there writing your
own articles a recording video or doing
whatever it is that you want to do to
share your information with the world
and the reason you do this is because if
LinkedIn sees that you're active on
LinkedIn they start putting your profile
in front of people's eyes over and over
again and then people will be like oh
wow I remember you or hey you know I
have an open position would you be
interested and you start building these
connections and building this sort of
it's the same thing like Nike does you
know the Nike stops advertising we
forget to buy Nikes and we go by adidas
so you want to continue to show up in
people's minds be top of mind as often
as possible and then yeah and so I would
say get it to a decent place continue
your job search and then as often as you
can try and keep your profile refreshed
in the activity section
all right Peggy with another question I
keep hearing it's a numbers game and I
don't personal I or I keep hearing it's
a numbers game and don't personalize my
resume but apply to as many jobs as I
can
is this valid I'd feel conflicted all
right there is a lot that goes into this
question so I'm going to try and break
it down the first thing it's a numbers
game so we're taking in the way that you
phrase this question what you're saying
is it's a numbers game I just need to
apply to as many random jobs on LinkedIn
as possible
that isn't necessarily the worst thing
you could do but it's not the most
effective thing you can do
just because you apply to 10,000 jobs on
LinkedIn doesn't mean you're gonna get a
job that's why like all these websites
indeed and all these things are sort of
affectionately referred to as the black
hole of applications what we want to do
is we want to utilize these resources
these great databases as tools to
identify what companies are hiring if
they're hiring for one role they're
probably hiring for a bunch of other
roles so when you see a company is
hiring that is a cue to go meet people
who work at that company
so it's both apply online and meet
people either on skype or in person and
then use both sides of the job search
meeting people getting a referral in and
you know doing your research and finding
things online and bringing it back
together so you can find those jobs that
are available so it's a numbers game but
it's a strategic numbers game if you
just blast every job with generic stuff
it'll be low quality and you won't hear
back much and if you spend all of your
time focused on one company also
inefficient you want to have a very
clear focus of this industry this job
this type of the thing that I'm trying
to do and then you want to go meet
people who do what you already do or
sorry who already do what you want to do
and then you find the roles and then you
reach out to the people you know and you
have them refer you for the
job so that would be the ideal situation
and the ideal way to play the numbers
game all right and push Kumar what is
the difference between a cover letter
and a resume big question all right so
cover letter the way that these two
things sort of came about is a resume is
a list a bulleted list of every job that
you've had in the past so that people
can see what your previous capabilities
were in a snapshot and asking questions
about it a cover letter is a short one
two four one two three paragraph sort of
pitch or sort of explanation as to why
you're interested in this company what
value you can bring and an expression of
how excited you are for this role so you
can't really give much emotion in your
resume you can't really convey what
you're excited about
or what industry trends you're looking
forward to it's more of a looking back
at your previous history whereas a cover
letter is looking much more forward at
saying hey I'm really excited about this
opportunity it looks like you're doing
amazing things let's say it's the
self-driving car space you're doing
amazing things in the self-driving car
space I can't wait to learn more about
this this and this because of my
background using these tools and I look
forward to continuing the conversation
so sorry I kept a very high level there
but the general gist is one is written a
written statement of why you're excited
for the role and the other is a look
back at your previous work experience
they used to be paired together in like
an actual letter format that's why it's
cover letter but now it's a mixture of
your online presence your LinkedIn your
resume your cover letter and all sorts
of other stuff that's out out there
online so just remember it's all these
things are just one piece of your
overall online presence and so you want
to make sure that you're keeping
everything in mind and not just doing
one one or the other thing
oh this brings us into duel Oh Collins's
question how can you build your own
brand especially when you are aiming at
being an influencer in an industry for
example the data industry this is a
great question and with my marketing
background I'm super excited to get into
it I've been thinking about influencing
influencers a lot lately and the ones
that I see who are the most successful
are the ones who spend less time trying
to brag about themselves and showcase
how great they are and more time helping
people solve problems so if you're
trying to become an influencer I would
first ask whose problems are you solving
and what problems are you solving and so
you might say okay well I really want to
help other developers learn a certain
language or I really want to help you
know I'm not quite sure well what would
be the thing maybe you can put it in the
chat I'd be curious you know who is it
that you're trying to help and what are
you trying to help them with and then if
you do that correctly if you can
actually find people to help and help
them your brand will grow and then
becoming an influencer because a brand
is is there no matter whether you're an
influencer or not so a brand is
basically what you think about yourself
what and what others think about you so
those two things added together so if
you don't have a big online personal
brand you still have an inner personal
brand which means people that I work
with know that I'm capable of these
things they think this about me and I
think this about me and so that's kind
of what my brand is becoming an
influencer is just taking what you
already are in real life and
accentuating it and trying to reach more
people in a bigger way so you'll want to
learn how to market you'll want to learn
how to do social media very well you
want to learn how to either write or do
video creatively maybe you want to host
your own event create your own Meetup
that's another way to become influential
and so
again I think if you make it your goal
to become an influencer you're kind of
pushing a boulder uphill but if you want
to just have influence and then maybe
you do that so well you become an
influencer I think that's probably the
better way to go because a lot of people
have influence who don't have these big
you know flashy brands they're just
really influential people in their
business so try and figure out what
balance works for you all right when sue
I think how can I ask people that I just
met or can with um LinkedIn to refer me
for position all right so you just met
someone and I I'm going to make a few
assumptions here and give a few examples
so one thing I see a lot is people just
sending the first message someone they
connect on LinkedIn so the person says I
don't know who this is but I guess I'll
connect with you and then the first
message they send them is I'm looking
for a job here's my resume let me know
if you have any questions now that
person that you just connected with who
doesn't know who you are who you just
assigned a homework assignment to isn't
gonna help you because they're gonna say
I don't know who you are
like why am i helping you this is a lot
of work and if you think about it
reviewing a resume is a lot of work
that's what people get paid to review
resumes and it takes hours of time and
it's very difficult and not everyone has
that skill so to do that is sort of
putting yourself in a negative position
so here's how you actually get into a
good position to ask someone to refer
you for a job what you want to do and
this is just one way to do it what you
want to do is you want to reach out to
someone in a very conversational and
flattering way so what you want to say
is in an email and this is what I send
of course
it's gonna be different depending on who
you are and who you're talking to but
what I typically say is recently I was
researching a certain industry so I'm
just gonna give a real example here so
recently I was researching the marketing
industry or let me give a better one
recently I was researching the Internet
of Things industry your name came up and
it looks like you're working on some
really interesting things would you be
open to grabbing coffee and chatting
about your work experience I'd love to
learn more about how you got into the
role you got and what you're working on
these days are you available next
Wednesday at noon coffee's on me so
that's a really nice way to open up a
conversation with someone that is all
about them that is genuine because you
do want to meet this person you do want
to learn and provides value not only
just that they feel good because
someone's interested in what they do but
you're gonna buy them a cup of coffee in
exchange for some of their time and you
know I love caffeine so in in my mind
that's something that's really good it's
a it's a nice trade-off people like to
get out of the office and chat about
what they do then you have a nice
conversation with them and this is
called an informational interview if you
you go in with great questions asking
them about what they're excited about
what they're working on what they hope
to achieve in their job what impact they
have all these great questions you have
a good back-and-forth and a good rapport
and if things go well what you ask and
next is at the end of the conversation
you say is there anyone else you would
recommend that I chat with and they
might give you a few colleagues or
someone else who works at their company
and then you say if in the future a role
opens up would you be open to passing
along my information and what you're
doing here instead of saying here's my
resume go do this for me before they've
agreed to do it you're saying in the
future would you be open to doing this
and because it's a future ask and this
is just a sales technique people are
much more willing to say yeah of course
you know this was a nice conversation
just send it over
and then maybe a week or two down the
road or months down the road when you
see a job open up you say hey it was so
great getting coffee with you a couple
of weeks ago I just saw this role was
super excited would you still be up for
passing along my resume here it is in an
attachment
now they've already agreed to do it so
of course they're gonna want to pass it
along you've all been coffee you've had
a great conversation and they've already
pre agreed to send along your
information that would be the ideal way
to get a referral into a company with
the stranger so that's a lot of work and
that's why we do these sessions and
that's why we coach people because it is
tough it's a I mean there's about ten
different skill sets you have to build
and want to do that but if you feel like
you can give it a shot and follow that
sort of linear thinking go out there and
do it I think it's definitely something
you should try and worst case scenario
they just say no and you move on to the
next person no big deal
we got one from Danielle seven to eight
how can I get a professional reference
when I don't want my manager or
co-workers to know I'm looking for a job
this was one that we talked about last
week a little bit but well you you
basically have to think a little bit
outside the box as to who else could be
a reference without knowing all your
details it's gonna be hard to get real
deep into that but maybe you can message
us separately and we can figure it out
but generally you're just gonna have to
look at friends family coat of school
mates
teachers you're just gonna have to think
outside the box ooh I like this one
Tamar how do you answer the question
that amounts to why are you changing
trajectories now especially if your real
answer is I got burnt out as a
journalist and fell in love with code so
burnouts real changing careers is real
not enjoying your job or being upset
about boss or any of these things
they're all real things and there is a
fine line between honesty and
complaining during a job interview so we
want to be forthright with everything we
say but we also want to tell the side of
the story that is the most relevant to
the conversation we're having talking
about burnout unless you also want to
talk like maybe they say a weakness
what's a weakness appears well I really
burned out in journalism and then talk
about how you had to leave journalism
and find a new column so maybe that's a
good answer to that question but in
regards to why are you changing
trajectories you said you fell in love
with code my question is what is that
story
what is the story of you falling in love
with code was it a certain experience
you had a teacher you had of course you
took what was the thing like what was
the mo
where you're like this is way better
than what I'm doing and I can't wait to
do it once you have that story when you
get that question instead of saying I
got burnt out in journalism and I fell
in love with code you say you know I was
working in journalism I was working
these crazy hours and then I started
this little online course and the online
course just totally captured my
attention and I couldn't stop working on
it I would come home from work every day
I'd go to the course and I would just
you know work day and night on this
project that I was doing and so I
realized as I was getting deeper and
deeper into this project this was what
was right for me I also started looking
at the industries and I started
realizing that self-driving cars are
gonna be the coolest thing in the future
and I can't wait for them to usher in
and be like our self driving taxis
taking us all around the world and so
that's why I started reaching out to
self-driving car companies and that's
why we're here today I'm really excited
to chat with you about you know the
displays that you put into self-driving
cars and learn how I can help make those
products better so that would be like my
made-up version of what you could say
instead of I got burnt out and film over
something else hope that gives enough
clarity but if you have more questions
of course put them in the chat
all right
all right Alicia cop Martin I'm a career
changer with experience in a completely
unrelated field would you recommend
including that experience on your resume
or LinkedIn profile I wish I had a
little more information on what field
you were coming from and and all the
details there but in general yes you're
gonna want to include it especially if
you don't have a ton of other things to
include in your resume and then what I
would do is Google translatable skills
and type in your position so I was
working with someone who was a teacher
and they were moving into I believe
coding and so we said well let us look
up top skills that every teacher needs
to have and top skills that every
developer needs to have and see where
they relate and so she just said oh
awesome so I'm gonna fill out the
bullets on my resume with these points
because they relate to this new job so
that's just a way to make sure that
you're explaining the unrelated in a
related way you can also do this by
looking at job descriptions and in
general like everything we've done is
connected so you know my work in
marketing informs my career development
work which informs my video work which
informs everything that I've done along
the way so things evolve but we stay the
same so your traits and how you
accomplish things kind of flow through
and people want to see how you handle
yourself in different situations for
instance I've actually given like
personal examples of like how I interact
with friends during interviews like oh
yeah back in high school I was always a
person who's putting together events and
trying to get people together like
that's not work-related but it informs
jobs that I've had as well and informs
things that I still do today
timing out of a twenty minutes left take
a quick sip hmm
I'm gonna jump down to Wayne Ben's
question how do I get free from tutorial
purgatory being constantly stuck in
tutorials I like that phrase tutorial
purgatory I've never heard that before
and I'm curious you know why are you
getting stuck in these in these
tutorials are you trying to learn new
things are you just getting more
recommendations from LinkedIn are they
required for something I'm you know I
got a lot of curiosities here but I've
learned to live for my online tutorials
I have no certification but I have the
knowledge in my head is it wise to put
it on my resume if you can talk about it
in an interview it's worth putting on
your resume and if you can give an
example of how you've done it you can
put it on your resume if you put it on
your resume and they say tell me about a
time that you did that and you have
nothing to say you're gonna be catching
yourself in a in a weird spot so I would
highly recommend only putting stuff on
that you can also tell a story about and
then if you want to get out of tutorial
purgatory probably the best thing would
be is to go build something take some of
the skills that you've learned in these
tutorials and see what you can go create
because if you can create five small
projects that relate to each tutorial
like one for each one all of a sudden
you're not in tutorials anymore and you
have five projects you can talk about an
interview in an interview so I the
tutorial purgatory sounds very similar
to a productive procrastination which is
the term I like to use for people who
don't know what they want so they go get
more education and they just keep doing
that until they're like you know I've
800 letters after my name and they've
never built anything but they certainly
have a whole lot of education and so
it's like I kind of view sometimes the
pursuit of knowledge without the
practical application as a way to
procrastinate what you actually need to
do which is build things and network
with people and go connect just because
you're learning doesn't mean you're
doing
LG good do I have a chance as a beginner
front-end developer to work remotely
yeah it's just a real tough one because
it depends on so many circumstances it
depends on the types of companies you're
applying for it depends on your previous
work experience but I would I would
probably say the chances of getting a
remote job is your first job right off
the bat are fairly low typically because
as a beginner you're gonna want training
you're gonna want to be in an
environment with other people learning
from each other
also if you've never worked remotely
before companies need to know that they
can trust you to get the work done
without having any supervision and so
when we created a series of videos for
you to acity career tips I've actually
put this question out to the community
of how would it people find their first
remote job and the majority of answers
where I slowly turned my in-person job
into a remote job over years so they
would be working full-time showing that
they can accomplish the goals of the
position building a good rapport with
their boss and doing all those things
then they would negotiate a few days
from home a week then they would prove
that they can work from home during the
week and still come into the office and
then they would slowly say hey why don't
we make this full-time remote and get
that first remote job then once they
have experience working remotely they
can use that as leverage for future
conversations of saying well I've done
this in the past and I've gotten good
results maybe they have their own
website that they keep updated so it
kind of shows that they have personal
responsibility and the ability to stay
on task with things and follow through
there's a lot that kind of goes into it
and the main thing you want to ask
yourself is if I want to work remote how
do I build trust with the person that
I'm talking to so that they believe me
when I say I'm going to actually do the
work that you're asking me to do so it
is tough it's getting easier and easier
is more company
adopt remote workforces there's actually
companies that are completely remote now
so it's not impossible for sure and it's
probably getting easier now than it ever
has been in the past but just know it's
it's a bit more difficult especially
because I they're typically not listed
as a remote it's something that gets
negotiated during the offer stage
there's a lot more nuance there but in
general I would say don't write off
in-person jobs just because you won't
remote you kind of have to go talk to
people and figure out who is and who
isn't remote and what companies are more
open to it and which ones aren't before
you start you know eliminating options
during the job search
what would a virtual information
interview look like and how should I ask
for one I'm looking for a remote
position this is Mariana hmm so a
virtual informational interview sorry a
little bit of gold a virtual
informational interview would look very
similar to what I said before about the
coffee informational interview in which
you reach out to someone and you express
that you're really interested in the
work they're doing you might want to get
a little bit more detailed and reach out
to people who have robust kind of
portfolios online and say like hey I saw
you or dude you were building this thing
I'd love to ask you a few questions
about how you put it together do you
have a half hour to to chat via Skype
and and just sort of you know learn
about what you do typically people are
even more open to that because it's so
much easier I know I've done lots and
lots of like informational phone
interviews for people and things like
that so it would be a very similar
process find people that you find
interesting and then actually is the
biggest thing find people you find
interesting if you're actually
interested you'll be much more genuine
in your conversation let them know that
you genuinely are curious about the
things that they do and the things that
they build and then just say you know I
really appreciate a half out of your
time I know in the past I've seen people
who really appreciate that send like a
five or $10 Amazon gift card to the
person or Starbucks gift card to the
person to say thank you afterward
because you couldn't buy them coffee in
in real life you could say here's a
coffee on me thank you so much for that
half hour so there's a lot of little
things that you can do that would be the
best way to get like a video one but you
could also comment on their blog posts
you know hey this was a great post and
then you know find their email and chat
with them a little bit maybe tweet them
that's also a really big thing that's
been going on especially in the
marketing world is people having twitter
conversations that lead to jobs so
probably my favorite example of this is
Instagram I know someone who's an
artist and she's constantly connecting
with people on Instagram and just saying
how much she loves their art and how
when she thinks they're an interesting
person and that has led to an incredible
number of in-person and online you know
professional relationships forming so
there's a lot of different ways to do it
you might want to do a little bit of
research on you know how to connect via
social media and just you know do a
little bit of a dive into you know
different videos and different articles
and stuff and see what see what they
come up with
all right huggy back with another
question do you know what I need to put
in my LinkedIn profile summary section
I'm going for front-end you want to
include that little elevator pitch maybe
make it a little bit more broad than the
highly specific one because you'll be
talking to more people on your on your
summary but if you're very clear on the
job you want to be doing make it
specific go ahead and then also include
your key skills the key skills that
you're going to be using in this next
job because it helps with the SEO and
then if you have any media I believe you
can add media to your summary as well so
those are all good things good starting
points for that all right we're getting
into our last ten minutes here I learned
at the co this is a Wayne Ben this is a
really interesting question I've never
gotten this one I learned about hacking
ethical hacking and an and I can do
basic hacking now a hack a laptop turn
on the webcam and more I can talk about
such or can I talk about these things in
an interview oh boy I would say yes with
a lot of caveats the question is how how
are you talking about these things if
you're and who are you talking to if
you're talking to an HR person they're
not gonna understand it as well as if
you're talking to a highly technical
person who knows what white hat black
hat and all that stuff is I would
probably stray away from turning on
webcams just because there is so much
like weirdness around that that
mentality and a lot of fear except when
has a webcam somewhere in their house
and then talk about you know why did you
learn it what what do you hope to be
able to create in the world because
you've learned this skill
because it is really cool and there's a
lot of people online who are white hat
hackers who have great personal brands
because they frame it in you know making
the world a better place so it really
has more to do with setting it up and
framing it correctly and then you can
really talk about everything just make
sure that you're talking about in a very
you know positive way and not kind of
just saying like it's super fun to hack
into people's computers and stuff like
that and although I'm sure it's quite
fun please don't hack my video alright
it's a summary similar to a career
objective these these are kind of all
interchangeable terms and what's tough
about the job search is that we've
accumulated everything over time so way
back in the day the way someone would
get a job is they would literally walk
up to the building shake someone's hand
and say I'm interested in a position
where they would call on the phone like
my grandpa got his first job when he
came from Germany by walking up to a
construction site with a bunch of tools
and just saying do you need help putting
this wall up we have over the many many
years put layer after layer after layer
after layer between us and the person
who hires for the role first it was a
resume then it was a resume and a cover
letter and it was a resume and a cover
letter and you know whatever else is in
there a middle person a recruiter that
your LinkedIn profile your social
profiles the artificial intelligence
systems that scan your resume like
there's just all these different layers
and what we want to do is just strip
away away the layers or go around them
and just get to real people that's how
you're actually going to form these
connections and when it comes to things
like your summary and your objective
it's like you just gotta get it good
enough like as long as it's not working
against you it's probably good now of
course one on one I would want to refine
it as best we can make it as you know
palatable and marketable and and
interesting as possible
but in a general sense as long as it's
good enough and you're there you're
doing a good job then the question is
you know who are you talking to with
this objective so if you have the actual
end person in mind all this stuff
becomes much easier I think the reason
that writing an objective or doing an
elevator pitch or even just applying for
a job but the reason is so hard is
because we're not getting specific
enough or not saying I want to work in
this industry in this job title for
these types of people and if we would do
that everything else become much more
clear can just go have a dozen
conversations with those people and have
in our head a very clear vision of what
we should be saying it's when everything
is so general and soap in the air that
we get a bit paralyzed in trying to fill
out those summaries but yes it they are
fairly interchangeable and if you read
anything says like write full paragraphs
and all that stuff I just realize that
communication has changed dramatically
and we live in a very quick byte
information world a slack world a
Twitter world Instagram world if you're
writing a full-page cover letter with
you know ten paragraphs
no one's gonna read it if you have a
resume that's two or three pages long
no one's getting past that first page
really try and be concise in the what I
like to call marketing materials that
you're giving people and then you can be
lengthy in your online content your
articles your videos whatever else you
create and we're in our last five
minutes here so I'm going to start
wrapping it up last one I'll touch on if
you have a career break is it wise to
mention it will have a negative impact
no Luca it all depends on why you had a
career break and who you're talking to
if you just took a couple years off to
not do anything it's gonna be a hard one
to explain if you raised a family it's a
totally different thing if you you know
took off to take a care of an elderly
person or took a leap year to go travel
the world there's a lot of different
reasons that people have gaps in their
resumes the key thing is that you need
to be
in the story you tell if you know why
you took it what you did during it what
you learned and what you're trying to
accomplish it's a it's not in it's not
something to be avoided but if you are
hesitant and you're scared of it or if
they ask you about it and you sidestep
it those are the things that get very
dicey so I want to I want to go deeper
into that but I just don't know enough
information but if you want to you know
send us some some more in details on it
we can we can try and sift through how
how exactly you should address that you
can do that in slack or in the Alumni
slack or on LinkedIn
just let us know all right all right so
we are running up to the end here so let
me see if there's anything else I think
I can answer in the next four minutes
how can you improve your social skills
if you're an introvert I want to end on
this one there are three types of people
in the world 40% of people are are sorry
20% of people am i quoting the stats
right
I think it's 40 40 percent of people are
shy 40 percent of people used to be shy
and 20 percent of people are not shy at
all so if you're in the not shy at all
you don't need this question if you're
in the 20 percent that used to be shy
you've already confronted this and
overcome your shyness but if you're in
the 20 percent that are still shy this
is the introverted question for you and
the answer is the only way you can
overcome your shyness is through X what
is called exposure therapy you have to
commute have to go put yourself in
situations where the things that you are
let's say anxious about or don't want to
do you are forced to get comfortable in
those situations so I used to be a very
you know introverted and shy person and
so what I did was I just forced myself
to go to as many networking events and
lead as many networking events and go on
as many copies as possible until it
became so second nature that now it
doesn't drain me the way it would
introvert right so and then and then the
other side of the coin sorry I'm kind of
conflating introversion and shyness
which probably isn't the best but the
other the other side of it is if you are
truly an introvert and networking events
drain you do one-on-one coffees find the
type of networking that works for you
maybe it could just be like yeah
grabbing coffee grabbing tea one on one
that's my preferred way to do it because
if I go to a big event with a hundred
people I'm useless for like the whole
next day so it's very helpful to sort of
find what works for you and then go take
care of yourself you know if it takes
you a day to recover don't go to four
networking events in a row four days in
a row go to one take a week go to
another but in between have one-on-one
coffees that are a little bit less
exhausting so I'll end on that one we're
coming up to the end here thank you all
so much for joining us for our second
ask a career coach join us next week
Karen's gonna be putting the link in the
chat for you to register these are
really exciting these are really fun to
do you know these questions kind of come
from all over the place and I do my best
to answer them there's of course way
more that we could dig into and some
stuff that I don't have all the answers
to but that's why we're all here we can
help each other in the chat we can share
these ideas we can take it in to the
LinkedIn comments the YouTube comments
the slack comments and really build a
group of folks who are all trying to
help each other navigate these big
career questions so I thank you so much
for your time for joining us from all
over the world whatever time it is by
you please take the survey and help us
improve our experiences here so you know
click on that link that's there so that
we can you know this is our second one
we've got a long way to go we got a lot
to improve so I appreciate you taking
that survey and sharing your thoughts
what went well what didn't and I look
forward to seeing you next week Thursday
same time for another career Q&A